open-minded to how we do that to be able
to stop break set and create the
positive liberal alternative for our
country I mean there is a test of this
coming up soon the by-election in
Bracken in Ratan sure I mean is that the
kind of place where you think actually
there is no good when there should be
one Pro remain candidate well we do have
of course Jane Dodds is the Liberal
Democrat candidate she has been a
campaigner in that area she is
absolutely amazing it will be a
first-class MP and it's a seat where as
Liberal Democrats we hold it in the
Welsh Assembly we have held it in the
past for many years so we do include
other parts so they know what don't
stand the Greens have just have just
decided that they won't stand in that
by-election and I think parties can look
at the the results on a seat like that
and come to that conclusion but a
different example would be the
Peterborough by-election where we were
very involved in conversations with the
Green Party and change UK to try to feel
a joint people's vote candidate there at
the last minute it fell through actually
those conversations got very far
advanced we had them at the political
level when I was speaking with Caroline
Lucas and chuck her when he was in
change UK but also at that practical
staff level so I absolutely think we
need to be open minded about working
with others because this is about
putting the national interest first and
I wonder how far you would go if you are
elect a new the Lib Dems when it comes
to working with all the others and a
national level if there is an election
which many think is going to happen by
the end of the year potentially the Lib
Dems could do quite well you could be
king makers would you be happy to do
deals with the Labour Party with the
Conservative Party well first of all
Sophie I would just say we could be
better than kingmakers I mean there was
a pool out yesterday that said that we
could actually in one scenario win that
election you actually think genuinely
you think there's a chance that you
could be in number 10 if you leave the
Lib Dems yes I think our politics is
volatile at the moment I think
predictions are a bit of a mug's game in
politics because so many things now we
have 12 MPs at the moment and you think
you could win the next election I do not
put any limit on our ambitions for the
Liberal Democrats because our country
needs a liberal alternative you know I
mean I watch that abhorrest Gillian do
you actually have 13 with chicken oh
sorry dude it does check her me to make
it 13 he made it 12 made it 12 okay
but I mean I watched drunk I mean I've
watched I watched Boris Johnson's your
interview with him earlier I mean this
is the man who is likely to be our next
prime minister and he bumbled and
blustered his way through that interview
yeah it was absolutely clear that the
only thing that was important to him was
the interests of the Conservative Party
the way it was all about his party and
Boris actually doesn't really care about
anything but himself
we didn't care about Nazneen Zakaria
Radcliffe he said he felt anguish showed
no evidence of it whatsoever and the way
in which he hadn't even bothered to read
his brief when he was appearing in front
of a select committee and you had that
woman languishing in an Iranian jail
separated from her young daughter I mean
he just doesn't care he doesn't care
about our economy you know he said eff
business well I mean at least it's
honest because his plans were breaking
well an F business he says that that's
taken out of context and that actually
he has been a champion of business in a
way that others haven't but he's not
championing business in what he's
proposing for breaks it because he's
sitting there basically merrily spending
absolute fantasy suggesting there's
going to be some kind of renegotiation
and you absolutely rightly put the
points to him about what you you leaders
are saying okay and there's no detail
from does not deserve to be framed I'm
keen to move on from Boris Johnson why
do you think the Lib Dems have been it's
so bad
at selecting and electing women well we
are getting better at it we now have you
know a third of her parliamentary party
or women and it's an issue that I've
been working on in the party for the
best part of 20 years now we're making
progress
but there is so much more that needs to
be done and you know it's a problem in
the Lib Dems and it's a problem across
the rest of society
I've literally written a book about
gender equality so there's a whole range
of different barriers and challenges
that are there and I think we rightly
adopted all-women shortlists
in 2016 and that did start to improve
the situation for us from the 2017
election but it's not job to have a
female leader now well I think I'm the
best person to lead the party regardless
of my gender but do I think it's
important to have women in senior roles
in public life do I think that that
makes a difference to young girls when
they look
yeah absolutely and I I disagree
hugely with the politics of treasom a
necklace sturgeon but do I think it is
positive for girls growing up to see
that women can run governments and can
can run the country yeah absolutely
that's important Stella Creasy has
recently spoken out about feeling like
she's been forced to choose between
being a mum and being an MP you of
course made news when you became the
first and please take your baby into the
House of Commons chamber and do you
think House of Commons is a good place
to be a parent it needs to be a better
place to be a parent than it is right
now
and yeah I mean there's a lot that needs
to change and we have started to make
those changes and it's tiring how
exhausting it is to get some basic
changes like the proxy voting which came
in in February but I mean that took you
know me being cheated out of my vote
when I was at home with my two week old
baby last summer
it took chillip Siddiq having to delay
her c-section before the House of
Commons eventually recognized we'd proxy
voting Stella's now taking up the
cudgels campaigning for better plans for
maternity cover for MPs and I
wholeheartedly support her in that
because we do need to make it better
for both men and women who are parents
because it's important our democracy is
representative now Sophia Ridge on
Sundays heard that your campaign is
mails out literature to people who
actually opted out of being sent party
political literature through the post
now people may have a very good reason
to not want people that they live with
to know that they are Lib Dem supporters
they may just not want to be spammed why
did you do that well first of all it's
be clear these are liberal Democrat
members but it is very important to
treat data seriously there was a genuine
mistake that was pretty minor and
technical it resulted in a tiny
proportion of people being contacted and
asked not to and we've apologized for it
and as far as I'm concerned that's it
are you sorry for it yeah absolutely I
mean we've made a mistake with said
sorry and then just finally you've been
talking before about people working with
other parties are you having
conversations with other MPs that you
think might affect the Lib Dems um I do
have conversations there are private
conversations I know you'd love me to
tell you about the content of them and I
could understand why but I think that in
order for people to be able to talk
frankly
what is a difficult step if somebody's
thinking about joining a new political
party then those need to be able to be
kept private without mentioning any
names do you think people may there may
be more defections I I'm hopeful that
there will be and let's remember why you
know you've got a Labour Party going off
to the left that is failing to deal with
anti-semitism in its party and is
absolutely failing to give any kind of
position on breaks that the biggest
issue of the day and they would face
allegations well I'm sure they would but
I mean if you speak to people in the
labour party about their experiences I
mean they are frustrated you know people
who have long supported that party are
looking on in dismay and that's why so
many of them are joining the Liberal
Democrats lots of labour members
activists have done so and took a munna
of course who was a Labour MP has joined
the Lib Dems and been warmly welcomed by
Lib Dem members so for people that are
feeling that they do not have a home in
the party that they once joined but they
share our values I just say really
clearly join us you'll be welcome okay
Joseph Winston thank you very much